c'est non non il est temps pour nous
maintenant d'écouter la voix de la
société je n'ai pas dit la même chose
c'est très marrant là en général au
procureur général en procureur général
c'est marrant le réquisitoire
je retire de la vie publique des poches
[Musique]
et bien j'ai président tu mangeras d'or
monsieur le président monsieur le rigolo
aux rapatriés
mesdames et messieurs les jurés public
fihri
trêve de balivernes ces deux points de
métaphore c'est plus la terreur
trêve de balivernes et foin des
métaphores en un mot merci sa lancée en
un mot comme en cent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais ces expériences je te demander si
j'ai réussi à ôter j'y suis a eu la
preuve que jacques auger de piau savoir
que je mentais la radio je suis très
content et bien justement mesdames et
messieurs les jurés vous le voyez c'est
la subversion que nous jugeons
aujourd'hui c'est la subversion qui
montre son mufle vis d'eux qui montre
son mufle vie de derrière ce box en bois
tendre je pense que c'est du merisier
oui mesdames et messieurs les jurés ne
nous y trompons pas ce n'est point un
simple rigolo atrabilaire chronique et
rothen qui se trouve devant nous mais
bel et bien un cas unique de gredins
subversif pathologique actifs à tendance
dépressive organico destructrice c'est à
dire qu'il se moque de la patrie qu'il
va presque pas la messe est pour ainsi
dire pas du tout revers
c'est pourquoi mesdames et messieurs le
jour et il nous faut savoir nous méfier
des comics subversif commente alors
comment reconnaître un comique subversif
d'un comique non subversif
quand on est con quand on écoute quand
on est confronté au problème est bien
bon et bien bon
et bien mesdames et messieurs les jurés
c'est fort simple le comique non
subversif cherchent à provoquer le rire
de ses contemporains sans vulgarité et
sans critiquer les vraies valeurs
civiques qui font que notre occident est
beau comme un camion par exemple comique
non subversive se met un faux nez de
poivrots pour cacher son vrai n'est
d'ivrogne ok ils se balancent un fromage
blanc sur la gueule tout en s'asseyant
sur un coussin pétomane tandis que sa
belle-mère marche sur une crotte de
chien à musique que le grand-père
cancéreux ça soit dans le fluide glacial
et quand chatouille l'érythème fessier
du petit dernier avec du poil à gratter
rires assurés bien sûr en revanche le
comique subversif ne cherche pas ce rire
franc et massif et de bon goût français
il poursuit le but de belzébuth il
conçut il poursuit le but de satan et
ils cherchent à provoquer seulement le
honteux ricanements chafouin des
salonnards de gauche
en foulant aux pieds les valeurs sacrées
que sont le travail la famille la patrie
et la bombe atomique
oui mesdames et messieurs les jurés
disons le bien haut le comique subversif
est anti communal anti départementale
antinational est absolument incompatible
avec le vrai rires français le vrai
rires français qui doit être rétro
zygomatiques ou ne pas être
je t'expliquerai il est une autre façon
fort simple de reconnaître le comique
subversif du comique non subversives le
comique subversif fait toujours exprès
de faire rire ses contemporains alors
que les grands maîtres du comique non
subversif qui font rire de façon innée
peuvent eux déchaîné chez-nous
d'irrépressibles hilarité sans le faire
exprès et c'est ce qui fait toute la
différence entre guy bedos et valéry
giscard d'estaing
et
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
fait étonnant non